[Music]
what's up dickies it is monday february
21st my son's birthday baby
big boy turned six big t big tigger big
tiger turn six years old man you just
wish you could freeze them in time you
wish you could freaking freeze them
um
yeah you wish you could freeze them he's
just uh
he's growing up man he was growing up
yeah he wanted a ferrari uh themed cake
when he asked that i was like this is
kid's out of his mind i'll tell you oh
damn where'd we get these ice cubes uh
mine
mike made this no
yes
oh [ __ ] that's fancy all right
wow jeez
things are really looking up at thick
boy all right big mike
damn
that's fantastic just want a little
drink here um
but yeah man uh you know birthday with
the kiddos god is their life different
than mine uh on my birthday my dad
you know i think got my cupcake and i
gotta watch tv what i want to watch that
night or go to a movie or some [ __ ] but
it is what it is man it is what it is uh
yesterday i i asked him i said what do
you want and he was like dad i just want
a slurpee because i tried that i tried
to monitor his sugar right because i was
like
sugar king when i was a kid and i think
it's caused some issues for me down the
road but um i i'm not like the weird
parent that doesn't want the kid to try
like you don't want the kid who's never
had a twizzler and then he gets to
middle school and then gets a twizzler
and he's [ __ ] you know
you know he's doing heroin you know seem
to happen a million times it's a
dangerous road to go down next thing you
know he's idolizing euphoria you don't
want that man i grew up on save by the
bell and uh
freaking dunker rouge you feel me so for
him uh i don't want to be the weird kid
who's never has candy because he has
candy but i do try to limit it somewhat
and he had a slurpee i don't know six
months ago and then now he just he
that's his like special treat or
slurpees when's the last time he had us
he only likes the original coca-cola
slurpee oh that one
he likes nothing else this is the
original coca-cola slurpee and then my
youngest son boston he doesn't like
sweets at all like i hit him with
slurpee's like get this poison on my
goodness oh my god all right my bad mr
irwin all right
my bad dog um
yeah b days man b days for the kids you
gotta make them special dude so it's a
good weekend man good weekend the family
uh then chris delia my brother from
another mother that looks like a bird um
chris delia was in uh
brea
he's in brea california doing shows uh
that's just artwork
that's me and chris there and i finally
got his don't push me merch on um
yeah i get the don't push me merch on
it's some of my favorite merch of all
time the hats are my absolute favorite
yeah dude
it's you know there's chris there man i
just
you know i can't say enough great things
about the dude you want to talk about
someone who's completely reinvented
themselves and you know
obviously went through some rough times
and
uh put in the work and you know gives
the therapy more than anybody i know in
my life and he's a great dad and
it's changed his perspective on life and
comedy and now he's talking about real
substance on stage and
you know that's that's how it should
work man that's called that's called
growing up
i find it interesting you know he he's
also a guy where
you know me and chris do shows together
all the time man and to me it's uh
i don't know if people realize the
amount of support that chris has so for
instance
in brea
it's it might be the biggest improv it's
up there and they even now that you know
cove it's definitely kind of
going to the side and we're moving on
with our lives think freaking god
but bray opened up even more capacity so
i think it seats
almost 590 now
he sold out six shows
at 590 and they wanted to add two more
shows
so chris is a guy you know in any market
can you know
he's in a you know big theater act still
man i mean i mean every oxnard same
thing the one that had three to four
more shows and just like dude it's too
much work you know i get home my kids
stuff like that which i love but i mean
you're talking what is that 590 times
six how many tickets is that
you know what i'm saying
so let's say to make math easy it's six
so that's what's that 3600 tickets so
it's
3540.
yeah that's that 590. 3500 tickets sold
i mean sold out like this they want to
add more shows so
you know talking
five six thousand tickets any market at
least a monster dude and crushing it
crushing it crushing it just a cool
thing to see cool thing to be part of
um if you guys watch
the other million shows i do uh king the
sting
where uh we announced that starting
march
i think second or third week of march
it's gonna go it's gonna change the king
the sting and the wing
clearly chris is the wing so this will
be theovonne crystalia myself
and two episodes a month will be on
patreon only king the singing the wing
it's under cats plus
and then the other
two are gonna stay the same so every
other week will be patreon um but the it
will still stay for free on youtube with
you know chris theo myself eric griffin
will be on the free ones but then if you
want just theo chris and i will be on
patreon
so uh yeah man pretty dope king to sting
in the wing so excited about that
can't wait
can't wait man we did a photo shoot for
it you guys see all that stuff but
the boys are back in town
yes great night man just an overall good
weekend
just good feelings good good vibes good
vibes uh let's get into the fight life
man in the fight life you had a fight
night
um i had to re-watch it on sunday
because i was working on saturday with
chris at brea
um you know it was a i would say that
this fight night was a better card than
what's coming up this saturday from top
to bottom but um you know
[Music]
this saturday's card suffered a little
bit
with our boy uh
daryush getting hurt against uh makachev
islam
who's an absolute savage but hats off to
bobby green man i mean
listen if you had to give a mvp for the
fight bubble that they were doing out
there in abu dhabi or the hell it was
bobby green was your guy he basically
went undefeated during the fight bubble
fought every other freaking weekend it
seemed and he's just a gamer man you
root for a guy like bobby green
and he said something interesting too
you know i'll see
what's so hot right now is fighter pay
right it pops it rears its head every
you know i don't know two years with
fighter pay
and bobby green goes up like i think
they asked him about it he's like you'll
never hear me disrespect ufc man i guess
apparently his brother passed away and
ufc covered all the funeral costs
so very cool yeah i don't know the story
with his brother pastor or something
like that we should probably get bobby
green on food truck and flashback fight
nights yeah dm for my account i love
bobby green his story is pretty
inspiring
um
you know i'm not saying anything that
the listeners especially my fans don't
know but
clearly a very tough fight against islam
makachev
but there's something i like about it
having this curveball i know bobby
green's a big underdog but to me there's
something to be said of islam getting
ready for a benillo derouche who's very
technical obviously if daryush gets hit
he has that
similar what cody garbrandt or even
gaichi has they have like that warrior
spirit where they just you know bear
down and start slaying him trying to get
the guy out there which i love i respect
except to fight a super high level like
that but obviously daryush is at a super
high level so is gaichi
um
but
the
interesting thing i think with this
matchup it makes me a little more
excited
i do think moktachev was going to beat
daryus i do and i love terry which i
hate to say it um but with much of bobby
green talking about a completely
different animal a different type of
breed you're talking about a dude who's
kind of you know hard to train for it's
gonna be hard to train for and i think
if you're gonna be beat a guy like
makchev or those dagestanians who are so
dominant in their wrestling and their
methodical and their you know approach
to fighting
the way you beat that is just a
curveball bobby green's a curveball man
it's not a terrible idea to go to
draftkings right now use promo code shop
and put some money on bobby green it's
not a terrible bet
now can you get it
you know
to needle hay stack
not a bad needle try to bet on though
he's a plus 500
a minus 720.
i mean i mean you know
makes sense
but i just think sometimes in this fight
world man you know if a guy's gonna get
it done it's a guy like bobby green
now my s would i bet you know my life
savings on bobby green beat them no i'm
just saying that a plus 500
put 100 bucks on them
win 600 bucks you know what i'm saying
so you know put a grand on him make it a
nice little payout it's a you know
[Music]
fun fight to bet on
[Music]
i'm not saying what it wouldn't shake
the earth if bobby green beat makachev
again very tough task but as far as like
curveball and stuff like that and
makachev the only knock on him right now
is
you know they say if he can get just get
used to the pressure being a main event
and dealing with the notoriety and the
the exposure that he's getting you know
he hasn't shown his full capabilities
yet in the main event
you know you talked to obviously um josh
thompson is a really good friend of mine
and he's around islam he's like i'm
telling you dude this kid is a savage
and he's like as good as he is and
obviously he's undefeated but as good as
he is in the ufc he you haven't seen his
real potential
so the more comfortable he gets the
better he gets so that's scary if you're
fighting him um but again there's
something bobby green is that curveball
man you can't really predict the guy
he's very explosive so
we'll see what happens with that man but
there's a reason why islam's such a big
favorite but i'm just saying if you're a
betting man like me and you like to take
chances taking a chance on bobby green's
not a terrible idea if you have extra
cash to play around with again if it
means
your your car payment or keeping the
lights on don't don't make that if you
have just some extra cash to [ __ ] around
with it's not terrible
not terrible bet because he's the x
factor it's hard to plan for short
notice huge underdog main event he's
experienced fighter very explosive hard
hard to train for so we'll see
i would assume makchev try to get some
down early on to take away and nullify
that kind of x factor that is bobby
green i would assume he gets him down
early on tries to break him and if he
gets them down early on wears them out
you can nullify that kind of x factor
and microchip is an absolute monster
when it comes to that so
um
you know it's you know the you hear the
same this is what's scary
about a boy hamzat is they everybody
says dude what you see in that gun is
like a tip of the iceberg like he's so
talented you haven't seen any of it
and i i saw a clip with uh
hamza you know he's training obviously
with gus finn that's camp darren till's
there and he's sparring with dale until
caught him fat boy come on fat boy he's
just such a savage dude
so scary
i saw some some outlets around the
headline shop thinks uspin can't beat
hamza now i didn't say that i'm just
saying it's a different type of animal
like you're dealing with we don't know
how good he is
and you know obviously camaro's
you know his knees are bad stuff like
that i'm just saying it's a different
problem from for camaro to solve
and it's just a matter of time because
once hamzad beats uh gilbert burns or
you know if he does beat gilbert burns
if he just demolishes them it's just
like
it's off to the races and all i'm saying
it's a different set of problems that
camaro hasn't had to face his entire
reign of pound for pound best in the
world that's all i'm saying can camaro
beat him yet dude camaro's pound found
best fight on the goddamn planet dude
i'm just saying i'm interested to see
if hamzad is the guy and there's nothing
better than being on that journey of him
being the guy makachev might be the guy
at 55. hamzap might be the guy at 170
you know and i love that stuff tomorrow
set
give him a golden jacket now one of the
best ever do it great guy inside outside
dr gun he's set so we know where he's at
um what gets me excited and what gets me
riled up is this mysterious kind of aura
around hamza
chin loves him
i'm loving him now yeah right took a
little while but now once he destroyed
your boy drangleic you were like all
right he's pretty good the way he did it
yes yeah amazing i know i can't get
enough of them i don't know what it is
mock chef too much as another scary
scary dude
scary scary dude let's take a little
break from the drama in the fight world
because this episode of the shop show is
brought to you by better help listen man
we all know we struggle sometimes and
something's interfering with your
happiness it's preventing from achieving
your goals something you've always
wanted to do don't be your own worst
enemy man get out of your own way that's
where better help can assess your needs
and match you with your own licensed
professional therapist i'm telling you
it helps man you can start communicating
under 48 hours all right it's not crisis
line it's not self-help it's
professional therapy done securely
online we got you covered it's worldwide
man you can log on your account anytime
send a message to your therapist right
you get a response back you can schedule
weekly video or phone sessions which i
recommend you don't want to sit on one
one time thing and you're cured nah man
it's it's training if you go to the gym
right you want to go to the gym once
like i'm strong enough nah man with
therapy it's it's training like you'd be
in the gym and you need it and it's just
you know it's your it's your your
brain's a muscle man you gotta work on
it you can't expect results overnight
after one time so commit to it man i
guarantee it changes your life right
better help wants you to start living a
happier life today and visit
betterhelp.com shop that's better help
help join the over 2 million people have
taken charge of their mental health with
the help of an experienced professional
in fact so many people have been using
better help they are recruiting
additional therapists in all 50 states
so i get a special offer for the shop
show listeners and viewers get 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com shop
everyone's busy out there man you got
back-to-back meetings you got erin's to
run you got chores pick the kids up from
school you got a list to do man you're
like god how am i gonna get dinner ready
i forgot something at the grocery store
what am i gonna do i gotcha cause my
friends my friends at doordash got you
covered man whatever you want we got you
man get what you want to eat right now
right to your door with doordash along
with the restaurants you love you can
now get groceries other essential items
delivered with doordash get drinks
snackies other household items in under
a freaking hour you know late night ice
cream we got you man you forgot maybe an
ingredient for that freaking meatloaf
platter we gotcha all right with
doordash get everything in one app with
over 3000 partners you can support your
neighborhood go to's or choose from your
favorite national restaurants like
popeye's chipotle cheesecake factory
ordering is easy and your items will be
left safely outside your door when you
choose contactless delivery drop off all
right for limited time the listeners and
viewers of the shop show get 25 off and
zero delivery fees on your first order
of 15 or more when you download the
doordash app and enter the code shop
show that's sch aub show that's 25 off
up to 10 value
and zero delivery fees on your first
order when you download the doordash app
in the app store enter the code shop
show don't forget that's code shop show
for 25 off your first order with
doordass subject to change terms apply
but yeah when i saw bobby green
everyone's like oh with the derrius i
agree i want to see him against dario
she's whatever
i think third in the rankings but
wow oh that's interesting just because
bobby green's that x factor he's not
going to be scared of makchev he's very
explosive he's dynamic it's a late
replacement so if you're islam and
you're hoping to fight daryushu and get
the title shot
you know you got to wonder what the ufc
is going to do you know if he was to get
by bobby green
you know so for islam is it a case of
like
all right you're fighting bobby green's
short notice what's bobby ranked
i don't you know
so for islam is if there's even a sense
of kind of a letdown he's not up for
this fight bobby green's a problem dude
he's giving a ton of guys problems he's
been fighting forever dude so i didn't
think
not even in the top 15. he's named top
15.
so dariush was three so for islam it's a
bit of a come down right
just mentally like what it doesn't fight
number three then i have a direct path
to a title shot so i assume you buy
bobby green and they got to figure out
what to do with them you know
we'll see
but uh going back to this weekend's
fights this past weekend's fights um
speaking of a come up uh
you know jamal hill johnny walker
um jamal hill right only has one loss in
the ufc um definitely
something about the dude man his timing
especially when it came to johnny walker
he was that one loss to paul craig uh
but outside that he's a undefeated
fighter man so
you know he's coming off two performance
of the nights two knockouts the jimmy
crew knocked out 48 seconds
and then the johnny walker uh his first
main event in the ufc
and you know he starches the dude
and as much as i you know i'll get into
uh jamal hill and how great he is and
you know i do think he's a top five type
of talent
i walked away from that after watching
just feeling sorry for johnny walker
because if you remember and you can go
back and listen to the i think at times
below the bell maybe big brown breakdown
whichever right below the belt we were
talking three years ago pray at least
when johnny walker came onto the scene
he's this absolute freak
we've never seen a guy move like that
you know i think he's far is it he was
the guy who's a former stripper right
yeah yeah he's a former stripper he
moves his hips in a way where you think
there's a bit of sugar in his tank like
there's
you know like i don't know guys that
move their hips i don't have sugar in
the tank so you but he's just this freak
dude he's six six
if you remember when we came on the
scene he's doing all this wild [ __ ] and
throwing knees and
knocking dudes out cold and if you
remember like even like two three fights
in we're like this guy might be a
problem for johnny bones jones i
remember same size unorthodox talented
you know super freak athlete you know
though he had like this x factor you
know we're so drawn to him then he wins
a fight does the worm blows his shoulder
out which is one of the most tragic
stories in ufc history blows his
shoulder out
kind of goes away rehabs the shoulder
post videos you know online of him
rehabbing and throwing punches and even
then you're like it doesn't look
fantastic
and for whatever reason during all that
he kind of lost his special sauce he
kind of lost what made him johnny walker
so he loses a few fights understandable
and then he goes to k was it uh john
cannabah yeah
kavanaugh's camp
and
obviously john's one of the most
brilliant minds to ever do it now he's
the you know the mastermind behind conor
mcgregor the biggest fighter to ever
grace the octagon
but part of me is like i don't think
that's what johnny walker needed because
now you're trying to make a guy whose
secret sauce was being wild and
unorthodox and you're trying to make him
a technical fighter there's not enough
days in the [ __ ] year for him to
download that data and be this technical
fighter so when he's in there
he's not really being himself is he he's
more of
i think he's trying to he's confused i
think he all right usually i love to
throw flying knees here but i've done
that in the past and i've lost or
you know john had me working on my jab i
could work footwork jab so it's like
this you're dealing with this guy who
really doesn't know he's struggling with
identity he really doesn't know what
he's doing right so
i think it makes him tentative i think
it takes away secret sauce and you know
johnny walker's kind of a shell of what
he used to be man and it's such a
[ __ ] shame to what it really bothered
me um
you know i see jamal hill you know god
bless them man that knockout and the
timing of the knockout was fantastic
but it wasn't like that was a clear shot
you know
behind the ear or something like that
you top the head to get knocked on top
of your head so then you got to worry
about johnny walker you know they called
his chin which it's more of a brain
issue right so i think
getting knocked out like that it wasn't
like uh well wobble you're talking stiff
yeah stiff stiff
scary knockout
i guess thing that bothered me and kept
me up at night is like what's johnny
walker do now
what's he gonna do
he's not a cerebral fundamental fighter
where he's going to teach mma he's not
going to open up a school
he has this set of skills his capoeira
skill set and jumping around it's like
we can't bottle that up and sell it you
know there's not a business plan there
you know he's lost uh four hours last
five
so you gotta you know how long is ufc
going to keep riding with this guy but
but like i said before that
you know he was on dana white contender
series in 2018
that got him a ticket to the chocolate
factory then they put him in the real
ufc and he fights uh khalil roundtree
who i love shout out to khleel he hits
ko l around that nasty elbow he hits ko
of the night that's in 2018. so that's
four years ago then they give him that
justin uh let it he knocks his ass out
in 15 seconds so the hype is real then
they give him a real contender and misha
and he knocks him out with a flying knee
dude again 36 seconds
so really you know khalil roundtree got
him on the map you're like holy [ __ ]
that that elbow's nasty then you let it
and you get a [ __ ] spinning back fist
in 15 seconds like holy [ __ ] and that's
where we're like dude with his size and
[ __ ] he might be a problem for john
thank you they're like all right well
then you'll see oh hold on let's see if
this kid's the real deal you're misha
who's a [ __ ] perennial kind of
powerhouse man he's a tough character
he gets dealt with in 36 seconds
performance tonight performance tonight
performance tonight now it's like here
we go then they give him corey anderson
and cory went cool story dude and beat
the [ __ ] out of him and court mary corey
felt disrespected and that was a big win
for corey and then corey went on to do
this thing in bellator and
[ __ ] like that but they set
they set johnny up to be the next guy
the next challenger for uh
jones because if he gets past cory
anderson remember that's the big ufc 244
if you remember
that was november 2019 that was master
square garden new york new york they
only bring out the big guns for that so
that that was their in hopes and
obviously they're having an issue with
cory anderson they were trying to get
him out of there right and they weren't
going to recite him of course i'm not
moving on
they were hoping that johnny would get
him out there with a flying knee didn't
happen cory beat the [ __ ] out of him
saying like all right just bad matchup
he'll learn and they give him cry love
and he loses that fight like this isn't
ideal
and i forget which one he blew his
[ __ ] shoulder out in yeah but it was
after a big win he just wasn't the same
then they give them ryan spann and he
kind of comes back
ko first round you know kelly is back
then he him thea go santos
lost in decision theo's a monster and
then they give him the young hungry line
and jamal hill and he gets absolutely
[ __ ] starch man starch i just hate to
see it dude i hate to see it
you know you look at he's like what he's
going to do obviously the chin's an
issue obviously he's struggling with
identity inside that gun that could be
your worst thing
so it's like you know what do you do go
back to [ __ ] stripping
you know that's not the plan
because the male strippers
just
you know
basically dance for other gay men you
know i'm not saying i'm just saying like
male strippers can't be a huge market in
it and he's a good looking dude
you know he's such a beast
such a beast
you just want the best for man that's
all i want
that's him right after the fight
i'm okay just a little cut here i sleep
in the fight
so something happened wrong proper 12
with my goats my energy
now a lot of pizza
okay
let's eat and be happy and let's go to
the next one
what a good dude
you know it's like yeah
for sure yeah he's entertaining it's
like yeah let's go to the next one four
out of five you'll see really don't play
that game and they have young bucks
coming up through the dan white
contender seriously they can pay less
yeah so i imagine they give one more you
lose that one you're talking five out of
six then we just just get we can't keep
it yeah it's like if you're a baseball
player you strike out a [ __ ] 200
times you just all right dude we just
can't keep it i don't know how how much
time you have that's not going to keep
you another thing is if you have chin
issues and i'm not even saying i hate
when people say i don't know if it's a
chin
issue but if you are gonna
suffer from you know that wasn't the
hardest shot and you have an issue with
with chin issues quote unquote and
you're at light heavyweight
it's tough man
now it could just be jamal hill hits
like a [ __ ] truck a mack truck and
he's that talented
i don't want this just to be about
johnny walker but i do find it
depressing what's going on here um
because remember johnny walker did go
five rounds with thiago santos who hits
like a god damn barbarian
i went five rounds he's all right
so for jamal hill i'd love to see him
fight santos next that'd be a fantastic
fight i love jamal hill's timing i do
think he is a top five
caliber type of fighter
i think what makes jamal hill
do i think he's more skilled than johnny
walker
athletically probably not his
fundamentals are better but as far as
like just that x factor johnny walker
has it but what jamal hill has
that
very few guys in the ufc have
that and most of them that have this
skill set are world champions going to
defend the belt many many many times
something dc has jon jones has tj
dillashaw had jose or josie aldo has um
dominic cruz has camaro usman has
francis has you look at you know
vulkanovsky has you look at all these
[ __ ] monsters that run the ufc
izzy has it of course
but it's their mentality
so at a certain level you know
especially at the highest level what
separates
the goats
from just the greats is that mentality
that
you know it's cliche to say but that
mamba mentality that killer instinct
that
true belief in yourself that never
falters especially in the day of social
media where you know especially in the
fight world right can be a little toxic
so if you have a guy who's so mentally
strong-minded
that nothing wavers and they truly think
that their destinies to be the greatest
fighter to ever fight
it it's so powerful but a lot of guys
you know that can get shaken with you
know a loss here or maybe you know they
have a a signature move that usually
works for them and it didn't work
against this guy and that stuff can
falter with jamal hill i see none of
that
he's you know he has one lost in the fc
you think that would falter or waver his
confidence you're just talking about a
guy his true belief in himself
true belief
you know he obviously is not the biggest
strongest guy he's not the most shredded
guy he doesn't look like [ __ ]
leonardo dicaprio johnny what if you if
you just went based off pictures like
this johnny walker is going to smoke
this jamal hill kid kid with two thumbs
up tattoos which i love
that tattoos are sick they just
thumbs up across his chest like this one
of my favorite tats
if you just looked at him on paper you
and you johnny rocco's goddamn praying
mantis on steroids dude he's jacked he's
six six
but one of them believes in themselves
one of them does it and it showed very
clear uh saturday night jamal hill
absolutely starched them
so jamal hill it's stuffed you know i
would like to give out mvps with a card
there's really
three of them man
that main card you know obviously
joaquin buckley you know we thought that
fight was going to be fireworks it went
to decision i thought joaquin got it
done abdul elassan is a monster that was
a good fight good back and forth i think
it's good for the growth of joaquin
buckley's career um then obviously jim
miller duke they're giving these young
lions against brazilian cat from the
contender series yeah jim miller's age i
think he has the most fights in the ufc
history
but it's it's between him cowboy and
andre arlovsky orlowski was the winner
of the most fights and then jim miller
so it's like whoever's gonna stick
around long enough
um it's tough but the why it's more
impressive and all of it's impressive
but i'm saying why it's more impressive
for jim miller because he's doing that
155.
if you go around the planet there's more
talent there's more contenders there's
more
people that can fight at 155 walking
this planet that you can't heavyweight
so it's going to be way more competitive
that's why the division is so goddamn
stacked in all organizations across the
world because 155
is more common than a heavyweight to be
a heavyweight it's [ __ ] impossible
right there's like 20 of them walking
the earth you can actually fight
so what what jim miller is doing at 55
should not go unnoticed he's our version
of tom brady he's the ufc's tom brady
and he's still getting he's still
performing at a very very high level and
he's beating these young lions and he's
setting these records and he's been in
there with everybody man every single
buddy he's been in there i like that
what they're doing because clearly
there's still
something left in the tank
now is he gonna beat you know
uh
these other monsters at 55 they're the
top five probably not but i like the ufc
has shown respect and give him the the
the guys that he's given them you know
he'd be eric gonzalez or the ko punch
last one he just knocked out this
nicholas mata you know in the second
round so
he's just doing the goddamn thing man
you talk about a
a hall of famer jim miller's a hall of
famer him and his brother two of the
nicest people on the [ __ ] planet if
you remember his brother he fought named
mark carter used to fight 85 but just
assaulted the earth dudes
so jim miller he'd have to give mvp
award to
and then with the heavyweights with
parker porter
his parker porter and this isn't any
shade on him he remains with peter
porker from uh peter parker
nope peter porker which is the pig
on spider verse
his name was peter porker so i see
parker porter yeah in my weird brain
that struggles sometimes with words i
when they call his name i'm like oh
that's spider-ham
he should
his nickname should be the spider-ham
peter porker it should be and his is
what
porter
parker
the spider-ham porter
how lit is that name dude in the
marketing selling shirts and [ __ ] but
you make a real jacked like big thick
boy spider-man that looks like it has a
pig's head you're welcome parker porter
parker the spider-ham porter it's lit as
[ __ ] here's the scary thing about him
he's massive his legs are [ __ ]
massive right
obviously he has a little excess weight
on him whatever he's just his pressure
and his cardio
was very impressive man and and his
fundamentals and his 1-2 and his
wrestling and he wouldn't get it now he
lost his first fight in ufc and i think
he's won three in a row now dude that's
the spider ham dude
that's the [ __ ] spider ham he lost
there chris uh dacas which is you know
nothing to hang ahead about that because
that chris doc is a [ __ ] savage
but i was really impressed with him man
really impressed with him especially for
a heavyweight with that cardio and those
take downs and his punching and take
absorbing shots because that bad oh you
know was lighting him up but the the
spider ham went ham dude he went ham
hopefully he likes that nickname no
shade parker porter spider him um and
then at the catchweight kyle dacas who
obviously his brother is the heavyweight
against jamie pickett
nothing more
that i like to see than a dark stroke
that was your boy [ __ ] when i was
fighting i'd love a dark choke
uh he absolutely dominated jamie pickett
absolutely throttled him didn't give him
a second to breathe
and what was interesting is when he
gives him that darsh choke
and i uh fancy myself a fellow darsh
choke can uh connoisseur
you can tell if it's locked in and it
didn't look that locked in i thought
jamie pickett was gonna make it to the
second round and he ended up tapping and
i but it was weird because he because we
popped that you can tell when a guy's
been
you know
having an issue breathing you know when
the oxygen the blood's being cut off to
the brain you can usually tell he kind
of popped up and he didn't come to like
he went out um
he tapped you know so something was
going on there and then
because i was like that's weird maybe
something's going on something was going
on jamie piggy came out on i think
facebook or whatever i saw where he said
my tongue was between my teeth and as
he's chomping down he was i literally
thought my tongue was gonna almost rip
off that's like that's why i tap live to
fight another day it's like no [ __ ] dude
yeah that's why because it didn't look
like a proper choke it was tight but
i've never seen worse i've seen guys get
through especially with three seconds
left they can usually fight it off or
they'll go to sleep find it off
and hold on that long isn't tight he
would have went to sleep we see him
tapped and you see there's no issues
mentally for him she pops up and he's
like god damn it but he said yeah dude
the reason i tap is my tongue was caught
between my teeth so he's clunk clanching
down my tongue was about to [ __ ] rip
off like oh no [ __ ]
tongue miss your tongue dude what the
[ __ ] we doing what are we doing here get
your tongue ripped out
insane yeah
so that's why i tap so shout out to
jamie pick it but kyle dawkis is a
problem he's good at everything and
obviously his older brother and him
train together so
philly's finest man awkward call out at
the end awkward call out i don't think
it's his thing he said yeah one thing to
say
he's like tony ferguson i was like
tony's way smaller than him where's he
going with this he was goes
i think he says you're known as the
darsh king
i'm the darkest king now or something
like that's knight darth vader it was
just it was just like awkward like it
was like it didn't seem like his
personality no i was like oh no somebody
told you to do that and you had it
preconceived in the back please don't do
that again just be yourself colin you're
a great dude you should shout out at his
mom which i love but that call i thought
he was calling a fight with tony
ferguson and then he was like nah i'm
the dars knight
the darsh king the king of the dark so
i'm the darsh knight something like that
it's weird to call it it was like it was
like right wait what what's going on he
wants to fight tony first in a dark
match
you're the darth knight which i like
darsh knight and i like uh
the the spider ham i like both of those
for you guys you're you got my stample
stamp of approval
um
so kyle docks looked fantastic
uh the spider ham looked fantastic
parker porter jim miller looked
fantastic joaquin buckley did what he
needed to do in his career to advance
and then jamal hill it's off to the
races i'd love to see santos next for
him because right they both beat johnny
walker he did it more impressively way
faster didn't go decision so it just
makes sense jamal hill santos is a
[ __ ]
main event on fight night all day or
it's a combing event on a major
pay-per-view or it's a third fight on a
major pay-per-view main card so
shout out to jamal hill man he looks
fantastic
yeah those are the fights for you guys
and you know you got a uh fight night
this weekend you did have bare knuckle
our boy chad mendes uh
get the job done which i don't think is
uh any surprise there suck to see my boy
get uh who makes fire music gets
starched
yeah and we learned his name is fames
from the broadcast remember you thought
it was farmers it's fames yeah i thought
i thought it was fun as you thought was
famous yeah that's fames
and we do have some highlights from that
fight and it was brutal dude chad mendes
really [ __ ] tank yeah he looks crazy
yeah there's some i'll play this one
first
now can the fans see these two they're
since they're um twitter posts i believe
oh cool
[Music]
that's a mike tyson [ __ ] there dude men
doesn't mean that's that might race
there's another one another one no you
went to decision no four knockdowns
jesus stop stop [ __ ] with the fight
chad man's just a little ball of muscle
he's the mike tyson of that like has the
short black shorts the black he looks
like [ __ ] mike tyson in there look at
his arm dude he's a mini me mike tyson
he's jackson jack now
poor fames dude what a terrible way to
do this and then let's just play this
last one
we kind of knew that i was gonna just
don't want that heat yeah it's just a
bad idea for a boy fame also fame's i i
gotta be honest man i wish you would
quit beer knuckle fighting in this weird
ring and [ __ ] stick the music yeah
your music is fired yeah
yeah i feel like your music can take you
so much further than this and if you
keep getting hit like
this it's going to affect your music my
man
no matter how many [ __ ] auto tunes
you use if you got cte we can't help you
in the music industry it'll be tough
that was a tough one yeah yeah shout out
to chad mendes who's the [ __ ] east i
wish chadman is in mike perry the same
size
i bet they still fight each other too oh
yeah dude listen
there are no rules if you're fighting
bare-knuckle just whatever's whatevs as
the kids say whatevs
yeah
yeah so you have four times to get the
fourth round victory james dude you're
so talented with music hopefully that
takes off for you man
we gotta link you up with little brows
who's doing the thick boy album yeah he
works with mike stud jelly roll
uh paul wall it's like dude
fames let's go i showed little brows all
the stuff and he's like dude i'm totally
right because he's he's super good yeah
did brows reach out to him um
fame's management reached out to me so
maybe i'll just connect him to browse
for sure that'd be awesome yeah we'll
get him out here and do something cool
man fames i got you dad don't don't let
this bare knuckle stuff get you down
just bare knuckle you know
all right so one of the things that
joaquin buckley did was hire this dude
he's like i'm sure you've seen him on
instagram or just everyone on social
media okay i've never seen him this guy
dale brown he created the thing called
dust and he does all those videos of
like how to survive if you get a gun or
knife or whatever but then people are
saying he's kind of bs and they don't
like him but he became a star anyways
online okay so joaquin buckley had him
as his uh
and he's like a
a social media sensation yeah yeah
that's something
[Music]
but i've done everything i need to do to
be in the best shape the best condition
he's talking a therapist right now
[Music]
[Music]
how do i increase my survivability
survivability how you spilled it
what's that man
maybe
something just coming to knock on my
door
so he ended up having him in his corner
and it's and the reason he did it is
because there's gonna you know this
guy's a viral star so he's like nope
there's never been a fight where more
people paid attention to his fight even
like celebrities paid attention to his
fight because he had him in his corner
oh so it's like a you know good
marketing smart marketing yeah
um
[Music]
yeah that guy's a big deal go to his
page oh that's him there
does he know anything about fighting
he thinks he does but
a lot of people think he's just bs but i
mean go to his page for me let me let me
look in this game i've never heard of
him
so with detroit detroit dust detroit
does let me see
remember joaquin
buckley got i mean even kanye retweeted
his knockout and did a song remix song
to it for god's sakes how do you follow
that up you hire this dust guy
threat manager i don't know which one's
this legitimacy
it's detroit that's the detroit dust one
detroit dust no go up the second one
second one buddy yep
that's what was tagged on uh okay there
you go that's on
so 380 thousand followers self defense
okay let me see one of his videos where
he's showing self defense
oh that's it right there
this is a crown bit knife it can be used
as an edge weapon or as a compliance
tool in this case he grabs here i don't
want to use the blade i pull here
or we can use it here and we can use the
back of the blade here and actually
create a lock we can also use the top of
the skull here to back them down or we
can use the chest plate here back him
away from you
that is several ways you can use it in a
non-lethal way in a case that there is
an attacker that's part of a group
whether it's armed with a weapon we go
here or you know
use the weapon to defend our life and
create safety for ourselves and our
family
these are intelligent options that will
increase your survivability fee and i
fight
is there another one i mean that i could
have done i mean he's just like if you
just
either grab you take the knife yeah now
you're assuming you have the knife in
your hand while you're being attacked
you sound surprised right so go to that
one where that guy's behind him
this guy yeah what's this
commander bro detroit urban survival
training it's four minutes back with
more ignorant comments that need to be
addressed
string comments
hmm
you know what i'm not hip to his stuff
too so maybe
maybe he's joking but who i don't know
he's not joking
no i know he's not joking okay
you can do hashtag self-defense for
women hashtag self-defense
smarter stronger equals safer
hey man not knocking the hustle maybe it
works
i'll tell you right i don't know if the
[ __ ] [ __ ] with these guns and stuff
all right so first one is shaking hands
he's sure
where are you gonna shake hands over
here oh you shake it
uh
no that's not real that's not
well that's not hey
well you know that's not gonna work so
you're gonna shake my hand then you're
gonna twist my thumb to a rear naked
choke unless you're dealing with [ __ ]
dumb mcgee there
yeah i don't i mean good for him i'm not
knocking the hustle if it works it works
if it works then great
it says it's for kids too so that's
great what else you got jim all right so
there are also bellator fights over the
weekend
you know the smaller ones though like
even gracie
uh but okay so this guy chance for
country he got kicked in the ribs by
andre andre korshkov who's a mosque
definite monster so he
suffered a punctured lung and five
broken ribs and that's the kick there
yeah yeah no [ __ ]
jesus insane
dude if you've ever fractured your ribs
it's hurt so bad because
they they take forever to heal b even
just breathing hurts
but um they take forever to heal because
there's not a lot of blood flow through
the actual ribs so they take forever to
heal this poor guy
what does he have a mountain dew there
looks like hell yeah
yeah but that's insane there's a rough
cake
um francis and ghana i guess he posted
something on his youtube channel
siding with jake paul obviously right
okay and just saying this particular
thing about the ufc uh in ghana we ran
it uh what is it reiterated that it's
possible it's possible
his
underscored the fact that he's reached a
point in his career where he's willing
to take financial hit to improve
conditions for fighters who can't make
the same sacrifices true he's talking
about fighters here yep they have debt
uh they need to borrow money to
subsidize their life so even though he
knows that he's not getting paid enough
he can't pass up the opportunity because
he has a machete on his throat
so he needs that machete is so
aggressive but all right how's he going
to fight against the system he can't
fight against the system he's just going
to take it
he or she's going to take it francis
just going to sit on his pride and keep
doing it and the power will keep getting
bigger on the other hand the fighter
will keep getting small on the other
hand
yeah i mean as far as
you know francine he's gonna take a
financial hit thank god he's at a point
where he's not gonna take a financial
hit that's why he can speak like this
that's also why jake paul can speak the
way he does freely because
it's not gonna affect them financially
um
you know you you wish more fighters
would rally around this but they can't
because
to france's extreme point of a machete
on the throat which is so aggressive but
i wouldn't say it's a machete it's more
of
you know the ufc doesn't have to do
anything because
there's enough elephants in the circus
who are going to get paid peanuts and
perform because they're just
a lot of them come from nothing and
that's all they know and they don't want
to you know go against the grain but you
got a guy in francis guy and jake paul
who are outliers so for francis i know
he says he'll take a financial hit he
won't because that tyson fury fight is
out there tyson wants that fight he'll
make more money more money off one
boxing match than you see could pay him
in [ __ ] three years so it's actually
you know in hindsight it's actually the
move for him no matter if the ufc plays
ball or not france is gonna be okay but
yeah to this point the rest the rest of
the fighters are kind of screwed
which is what it is yeah
all right this is volkanovsky talking
about
max holloway because you know there was
originally supposed to fight and then
max had an injury had to pull out and
now max is getting healthy again so he's
actually a backup on that same car with
korean zombie and volkonovsky so he's
called up you backed out now you're yeah
replacement so this is volkanovsky
tweeting at blessed mma that's max
holloway for you guys don't know once we
back up fighter or fight he was really
skilled to fight so in other words he he
was never injured just hoping he doesn't
have to fight me or fight me while i'm
prepared for someone but hey if you
ain't cheating you ain't trying no
it is a little weird to back out a fight
nothing the replacement yeah but
this is this [ __ ] i don't mess with with
max hollow and you look at his
reputation you look at his
uh just
career in general max isn't afraid of
anybody so i don't think it's that maybe
max thought
the injury was gonna be more severe and
he's actually bounced back for it and
then they they announced the korean
zombie fight and he's like [ __ ] i can
kind of fight now and i bet his team
told the ufc that like whoa we don't
confuse people we're going through with
korean if
volkanovsky wins you you guys will
reschedule that right away so i'd be one
to bet max went actually it's not as bad
as i thought
i'm actually training back to training
like right well you'll be the
replacement if something happens but we
can't keep going back and forth
for volkanovsky this just builds the
fight with them even more so i get it
but
to say max is scared of anybody it's
just insane yeah look at the dude's
track record
[Music]
okay so uzman versus give me a favorite
chain go back i saw something that was
interesting here uh then scroll over to
the right it was another headline
with the where they had the uh no no you
were no no where you were at with uh
then it says
uh ufc veteran blast clown jake paul for
fake fighter pay interest what's that
let's see
who would
veteran uh sam alvey oh the smiling
ufc veteran sam alvey isn't buying what
jake boston when it comes to country's
little issues fire pay uh we know paul
yep in addition that paul yeah okay
during a recent interview jake paul is a
clown he's he's not trying to help
fighter pace trying to help himself
every fight sells when you either want
to see somebody win or see somebody get
knocked out jake paul has figured out
that everyone wants to see him get
knocked out so he wants to try and
switch the narrative and he's and so he
goes after the low-hanging fruit that
sounds great to run pay fighters more if
ufc dana white any of those guys were to
do what jake paul is asking he wouldn't
get us paid more he would eliminate the
roster of the fc we'd go from roster of
800 down to 75.
ah
i i mean do i think jake paul's doing it
because he actually thinks he can make a
change i don't know here's my question
does it matter because he's doing it
he's doing it yeah sam out sam alvey's
never done it sam alves never had the
success of jake paul to do it to really
make a change
so i don't care if it's low-hanging
fruit clearly it's the elephant in the
room
and jake paul's just the guy who's
untouchable uncancible and far as the
fight culture goes so he has this
massive platform so if he wants to run
with the narrative because these other
big name stars nfc can't because they'll
be disciplined more power to him
i mean i don't know why if you're on the
uc roster if
you definitely don't want to go against
jake paul because all he's really again
whether it's to get more views or more
haters whatever i don't give a [ __ ] but
he is bringing a high and has the
platform bigger than anybody else in ufc
to actually make the ufc address it
sam alvey it's like
i mean even though maybe you think he's
doing for a different reason who gives a
[ __ ] what the reason is yeah if it gets
done highlights fight or pay also
you know
with sam alvey going we'd go from a rash
of 800.75 that's not true you ever seen
how much money the ufc makes and that's
the problem that's the problem because
sam alves so and i think is he retired
or whatever i think he's done he's lost
a bunch but you know for him to go we go
from 875 so you've seen he keeps doing
what they're doing
dude you're drinking the kool-aid you're
in this weird
weird freaking cult and you're drinking
the kool-aid man you step out and you
look oh man we probably could be paid
more
but he made the news
all right so real quick on jake paul as
well there's a thing that eddie hearn
said kind of basically what you were
saying too
jake paul is a disaster for the ufc
eddie hearn claims youtuber turned box
will anger dan white because he has
his b in his bonnet and is on a mission
to improve fighter pay yeah again
whether it's you know an actual mission
and proof fighter pay or if it's just a
marketing ploy we don't care he has such
a massive platform he says anything all
these outlets pick it up
if another fighter says something unless
you're one of these champions no one
cares dude it's just a attuned fighter's
been singing since as long as i can
remember but unless you're a big mover
nobody cares jake paul's the biggest
mover whether you like him or hate him
who cares dude
so just don't do it just leave it but
isn't what we want we want views we want
interest we want drama we want
confrontation we want hype we want
narrative that's our job isn't it so i
think they complement uh complement each
other in that respect he added there
will be more pressure on the
organization as time goes by especially
with the voice and noise of someone like
jake paul yep me and eddie hearn um jake
paul's a disaster for those guys he is
sincere but i think he's got to be in
his bonnet and he's having fun with it i
think he's on a mission but i do think
he feels the ufc fighters underpaid yeah
for sure i agree i think he knows
underpaid but no one's been able to do
anything again with his platform to keep
bringing this up
you know i don't and again the ufc is so
powerful
and it's really not on jake paul to do
this but the ufc is so powerful
um i even at with at his scale at jake
paul's level and he's bigger than anyone
in the ufc i still don't think it's
enough to get it done
it's cool of course talk about it makes
headlines but
again i don't know the business model of
the ufc i know they made the most money
they've ever made last year and people
always ask me oh fighter paying this
it's like
i don't know how they clean their house
man i don't know i know i clean this
house we do pretty good and we pay guys
fairly but i don't know what they do and
also they don't have to do anything
because when data says jump every single
fire that roster goes how high
every everybody
because the ones that actually can make
a difference are getting paid dude
they're making good money that you guys
don't care about those guys are getting
paid dude
that's that's how you keep this circus
going is you pay the guys that can make
a difference they're they're fat and
happy
yeah well he was saying that
just dana making that video to reply to
jake paul was like that's not the move
just leave it alone yeah don't do that
you're making more
attention to it it's more yeah but i
think dana also said on full set and
he's like i'm done talking about this
kid man no more of course he knows you
know
it's also a war on social media it's
just not your thing now if there's a war
of contracts and matchmaking and
promoting
fights then that's dana's late but it's
not you step in this weird world where
it's not you know
it's just not your thing
all right well we knew this was going to
happen but so kamar usman versus leon
edwards 2 is targeted for july despite
that uh usman had like legitimacy
yeah it looks pretty crazy hopefully
he's all right man yeah so july
i'm on for it i'm all for it
and you mentioned the hamzat and darren
till training so this is more footage
here and he said he got his ass kicked
there until
i don't want to play music but there's
that out against the hill right there
yep
so again the arm bar there
so but i do think you gotta
you gotta take your hat off to darren
till because he was like all right
hamzat's this absolute monster when it
comes to grappling that's something that
clearly isn't till's cup of tea so for
him to get out of his comfort zone fly
all the way down there can't be cheap it
shows you how about he wants it and
despite whatever till has to say about
me i root for that i tell you guys us
all the time my life's too good to hate
on a guy like till
i don't have the energy to do it i don't
have the time life is too good man so i
root for till i really hope he can live
up to the potential that you know we
haven't had a face of uh
england or european fighting since
michael bispington and darren till has
that he has the his gift of the gab he
has the skills it's just you know he's
fallen on hard times i really hope he
figures it out man i really really do
yeah it's like more of the mental thing
i think he's got a face like when he
loses like when we left the uh bronson
you know my guys are like yo your dms
you're like oh dude yeah fire this meme
they're sending me like that's not i
don't want to see this guy lose dude i
wanted to win man yeah i root for darren
tail dude
all right well good first move to go
there with hamza yeah hats off to man
because that must be a nightmare you
know
and again we talked we we've been on
homs that's nuts for how long now we
talk about how they say how much of a
badass is in trading
and for tail to go i'll go down there
it's pretty gangster dude yeah hats off
to him respect definitely
um so luke rockhold has always been kind
of in and out we didn't really know his
next move so he's saying he's targeting
a june return and he wants to fight paul
acosta what happens with the strickland
fight's just over
i think strickland is there's another
thing where he's gonna they're thinking
he's gonna fight someone else was it
strickland is yeah oh that i think yeah
paul acosta but so this is just luke
rockhold saying he wants a junior turn i
would like well i mean for strickland
i've seen paulo costa cause the rape the
rankings but
i like the matchup of luke rockhold
strickland because they've trained
together and also i saw luke ruckle go
you know through all the drug use and
all that [ __ ] that's why strickland's so
crazy like he was like i don't he's like
that's what makes him dangerous like he
doesn't even know
what he's doing like there's no
reason behind it he's just going because
he's crazy
he's like which makes him super
dangerous
basically saying ignorance is bliss
i'm not saying i agree with that i think
strickland is a very smart fighter
that's what makes him special i think he
showed that with his jab the last fight
and uh i saw rockhold say he just
doesn't have a killer instinct
i disagree i mean you know
probably that's the number one thing
yeah i think if anyone has it he's
talking about he wants to kill again he
wants to actually chelsea claims ufc is
aiming to book golden goose sean
strickland golden goose that's they're
they're marking as golden goose that's
what trails said golden goose sean
strickland vs paul costo uh number one
contender fight with one condition
there it is it's a crystal clear sean
strickland is one win away from a title
shot well then let's go back uh to the
rumor at hand which is paulo costa i
love in a fight when we have a semifinal
match i agree nothing better when we
have a number one contenders match
extremely rare more common is to have a
big match if this guy wins in this case
sean strickland he used to fight for the
belt but that doesn't mean it's the
number one contenders match because this
guy in this case paul cuss wins he does
not yeah but it's kind of like paulo
costa's fought for the title
um you know police is still a [ __ ]
dangerous dude
it would be such a fun fight and we're
after sean stricken's fight that's
that's what i said i want to see next
yeah it sounds like an awesome fight
great fight yep
all right i know the truth tory luke
rock would be fun too
so i chose under another rumor he said
he talked to stephen's wife and then
stipe is now 249 pounds he put on 20
pounds of muscle
i'd i dig it i would say he's now is he
putting on muscle because he's gonna
fight jon jones no idea
because you know john's super thicky
right now i mean he draws a thick boy
she said him garrett don't know if he's
going to wear it but john is a thick boy
dude i i just
you know in my experience i don't like
it i think we go up to heavy weight the
thing that makes john special is his
cardio his creativity his quickness you
know so when you put on weight all that
slows down and then you're just like the
rest of the heavyweights you know so
have you been around so
sleepy
yeah yeah when bef when he first signed
the ufc uh me and him were training
partners for two years oh should not
yeah so their size difference when you
knew like when john was making stupid
were the exact same size oh wow two four
we were both around 238 240. same height
the exact he has a his head's four times
yeah he's like that's why he can eat
shots
true
no cb is a great guy workhorse mean him
dude i wish i had the footage to meet
him sparring because i was like just
coming up i think i
i just knocked out crow cops i was like
that hype around me steve was just
coming in he had the baseball background
he was coming to denver because they he
was getting into the ufc and they wanted
to train with heavyweights and we had
you know shane carlin myself so i think
shane flew him out to denver to train
with us so he's with us for a few weeks
and when i talked about dude we were
going for blood man because it was like
this two young lions trying to prove
who's the best and dude
yeah dude dude we had some [ __ ] wars
obviously goes on be you know graceful
time and i tell dick jokes so that's
cool
uh so this is trail talking i got inside
scoop i guarantee you guys haven't heard
this
you might remember steve bay after
francis said i'm stopping everything i'm
putting on 20 pounds right 20 pounds of
muscle is very different stipe i just
got the inside scoop inside scoop you
just called his wife joe um just talked
to stevie's wife cbs249 you're welcome
yeah i you know i
the hope hopefully helps stephen you
know
and this is just science when you put on
more muscle your cardio goes down no
matter who you are so one of the things
that makes steep specials is is cardio
so if you put on 20 pounds of muscle we
got to worry how that's gonna affect his
cardio he probably hits a little harder
he's probably a little slower um so
we'll see and also to put on real 20
pounds of muscle
very tough yeah especially at his age
very very tough
all
right uh it's just a few foul uh fight
announcements curtis blades and chris
dawkis will be the headliner for usc
columbus remember alexander rakitch and
blakovich was supposed to be the
headliner but then
blakovich has an injury with his neck
that's an interesting fight from this
darkest man yeah right after louis ii
right yeah chris blade's a tough
character yeah
oh yeah doc is the duck still in the
fight
got knocked down and that god damn the
throne to the goddamn wolves he's up
there though all right so yeah dude the
ufc is so savage
oh you lost to derrick lewis here's
[ __ ] curtis blades yeah curtis is
such a knight curtis just the guy he
would be
the heavyweight champ of the world if
you know obviously ran into francis and
you know derek lewis
it's just he has a skill set to be world
champion just happens to be born at the
same time these other guys in the
division
it's a tough fight man yeah
definitely
this one i thought was really cool
melvin manhoff and yolo romero
headliner for bellator paris
two old dudes but
like really
explosive
fun fighters
you don't like it
i i don't know what to make of it i mean
okay yeah melvin you know he had uh
annihilated by our boy
yeah um
yeah all right i'll watch it you know
it's interesting it's such a weird fight
weird fight it's what belter does
sometimes yeah for sure it'll get views
yeah and a quick one another
rematch aj mckee versus patricio pitbull
twos for april
i mean aj mckee the most talented
fighter in bellator by far superstar
do you think they'll ever
allow him to come over never
they'll be there michael chandler and
then in
eight years finally he'll
want to test you know and see where he's
at with ufc that's how this goes yeah
alrighty um aaron pico
versus jeremy kenny i had to look up
this guy's record because i wasn't sure
who was
but
not too bad
yeah pete they're still bringing pico up
you know they're still bringing them
yeah
i love aaron pico
and then on that same card vidcon corey
anderson yeah that's the grand prix yeah
i love that yeah and our boy john wayne
parr his retirement fight at one this is
the last one yeah one championship shot
to one championship
uh fly yeah
follow young first retirement fight oh
that's cool man yeah when is that
saturday march 26th
it's just around the corner
god i hope jim
i know when part wins so that would be
his 100th win if he wins it jesus christ
so that's why he wants to go on top you
know
with the honorable freaking
yeah john john wayne park is a legend
dude
uh so
this fight with bobby green is gonna be
a catchweight with makachev at 160. yeah
and chelsea has some thoughts on that if
a ton of six pounds does that mean you
actually weigh in at one six pound 161
or they made it 159 like
the whole thing gets weird i don't know
where this allowance pound ever came
from why you can't have it in every
fight except title fights the whole
thing is just goofy but they're they've
they're spotting him five five pounds is
there anything to see here is this
something i'm missing is this relevant
who asked for it we'd have to believe
bobby did we know bobby can make weight
because we saw him do it 13 days ago
that's the problem
uh he's got another 13 days 14 to make
the same weight that he just made but i
don't think islam would ask for the
weight allowance because of a change in
opponent because this is almost planned
on doing anyways yeah i think it uh oh
there you go bisping explains why
there's a good chance by regretting the
beats ship there you go but um
[Music]
there you go bisping great might think
alike buddy
um
[Music]
but for bobby green to cut like hit that
weight cut is excruciating for a lot of
guys so do it back to back
his team was probably like dude we'll
take the fight but you gotta give some
leeway here i could take it but we need
five pounds because those last fight
five pounds actually kill him he can do
it once every four months but to do it
back to back in 14 days is too much for
the fighter i'm sure the ufc is like
yeah that's all you want let's do it
yeah it's a it's a bobby green's team
thing was like dude it kills him those
last five pounds he just did it if you
want to take this on short notice
obviously give him some nice little cash
here and then give him five pound
allowance that's how it goes it's not
goofy it's the way you get the fight
done chill when you were fighting
because i've seen this happen before
where people say uh he just had a fight
camp so a close fight after let's say he
just fought today and then he takes a
fight two weeks later a lot of people
say
oh that's actually good because i had
this fight camp behind him when you
fought did you have after a week or two
were you still in prime condition to
fight no not at all because usually the
camps are so intense the camps that beat
you up and depending how your fight goes
you know the fight can be tough but
nowhere near your camp so you need those
breaks after because if you're doing
running a proper camp you know six to
eight weeks you're it's full there's no
way like by the time you're done with
that camp you you can't wait to get to
fight week just to rest
and then on top of that these guys are
cutting weight
so they really that that time off is
vital for these guys especially if
they're cutting weight
vital
yeah let's see what happens with this
fight
yeah it's fine i'm all for it
all right this is also i guess a rumor
you'll see that ufc is working on ortega
versus yara who's a mexican on mixing
crime i'm with it
that's a great fight speaking of brian
ortega he posted this recently on his
lip mm-hmm
he says he's in love
and what's that say
oops
uh tracy cause that's those girls yeah
yeah
god that must have [ __ ] hurt on your
[ __ ] lip
yeah but that's love you gotta hold your
lip there like that
yeah i guess
when you tattoo your lip you gotta hold
your own lip right oh yeah
you [ __ ] better [ __ ] hurts dude but
it should be pretty quick that guy's
taking forever that hard done so let's
just get going
that's dope though good for him
uh this one's not that big of a deal
but that's cool this i thought was
interesting so deontay wilder we haven't
heard from in a little while
he's actually working on music now
and i'll show you what he did here
[Music]
he's playing the saxophone
that'd be sick just some old-school jazz
play that'd be sick
[Music]
he sings like r b
what do you think chin
you know music
[Music]
is
[Music]
it's very uh have you heard the guy from
90 day fiance no that's yeah there's a
guy talks like that nigerian yeah it's
very like you know island like
yeah well that's what he likes to do
with his off time seems like a lot of
people are getting into music now so
that's yeah that's pretty cool yeah it's
cool and he also was on this
show and he's saying that he wants to
take ayahuasca
and then after that decide what he wants
to do with his future because you know
he's kind of like in limbo right now he
doesn't want to know what he wants to do
that's good for him man yeah if he
he's made enough money to do whatever
the [ __ ] he wants to do which is great
yeah i listen to so many especially
comics so many people doing ayahuasca
these days i know so many people do and
they get great benefits from it so if he
wants to do it and then think on that
that's good
i heard you're forced to address some
real demons
i've heard some stories about like oh
man i don't want that man it's so crazy
how that stuff works too i i don't i
don't want to see that stuff either but
i feel like yeah addressing it is
probably the best facebook facebook
it's too scary for me though
um you might be a little jealous of this
oh
do you think khabib realized how big of
a deal that is that's what everyone's
making fun so i think uh on our think
boy group chat someone screenshot that
and sent to mario holy [ __ ] that's the
pound for pound entertainment goat jared
leto with the dagestanian
[Laughter]
yeah but you know i guess uh khabib also
says that he didn't know who drake was
so people definitely if you don't know
who drake is definitely like jared
leto's doing wrong is a big deal but
trey there's like does he think do you
think he actually knows
who's just talking to probably not but
i'm sure jerry loves a nice guy yeah
great guy you know
is that it that's it for current events
all right kids fun show another one in
the
books um
we are dropping a flashback fight night
with matt matrione this wednesday on
thick boy again i've hyped up the shows
with matt man and uh
they're some of my favorite ones i think
you guys gonna dig this we watched three
fights uh in matt's career the first one
is matt versus myself which was super
awkward but we got through it and then
we watch his derrick lewis fight in his
fedor fight so uh
it's just interesting perspective uh
matt's view on when we were fighting
each other in my view completely
different
um
i love doing the show man
so uh you know the first one's up right
now with sugar shawn o'malley that's the
flashback fight night on think boy right
now that's on youtube if you haven't
seen it and uh wednesday it drops with
matt matrione we got a food truck um
with michael chandler dropping we have a
food truck with mitrione dropping a
flashback fight night with uh
chandler dropping and then we have a
very special squad showing up for the
cabasa's fight companion march 5th for
ufc 272 we have josh barnett and
mitrione and myself so if for you guys
are looking to check the box for fight
heavy
there you go pipe down so uh that's it
man and you have a fight night this
saturday uh make bobby green and i'm
fascinated by it even more so now that
bobby green is the curve ball in this
whole um kind of fight world man so um
let's see mike chef has his hands full
with this different uh problem to solve
with uh you know bobby green so i'm
excited for that you also have bellator
mousasi versus austin vanderford um aka
mr paige vanzant but he becomes a world
champion and now she's mrs vanderford
yeah you feel me so i'm rooting for uh
austin although gay guard with that big
dick energy's hard to beat
all right you feel me uh a few
uh touring notes uh wednesday this
wednesday shop and friends it's
crystalia brian callan jeff dye
chappelle lacy myself one night one show
only this thing will sell out um it's at
8 p.m at the hollywood improv in los
angeles california this will be our
fifth sellout in a row so get your
tickets as you're listing this because i
guarantee we're gonna post it today the
[ __ ] is gonna sell out and then also
this week thursday friday saturday
sacramento it's the capital of
california baby um go say what's up to
newsom sacramento california is
punchline
comedy club and that's february 24-26
that's thursday friday saturday the
show's almost sold out i can't add shows
for a variety of reasons the late shows
are sold out so early show tickets are
left get tickets right now at
thickboy.com or f a t k z dot com and
then march 10th through the 12th i'm in
one of my favorite clubs in the world
zany's in nashville tennessee march 10th
through the 12th we'll have a special
guest there as well and then just added
to the dates is chicago illinois march
24th to 26th so get your tickets at
thinkboy.com or
fatkz.com the calabasas fight command
first merch drops this tuesday we have
this oops grenade uh hoodies tees and
hats drop in tuesday so i'll blast all
over my social media and you guys will
see it but any thick boy merch we have
the thick boy
car club stuff and then also the cowbest
fight companion oops grenade shirts uh
drop this tuesday at thickboy.com so
that's it kids love you thanks for
watching subscribe like tell your
friends be safe out there i'll see you
next time
you